and then they just like just like came
up and just like biting them and I
couldn't see everywhere if Sony's the
shallows Blake Lively trying to survive
against a mean ol shark is trying to
eater so today we're gonna swim the
Sharks we're gonna swim with sharks I
grew up in Florida basically I know the
water like it's the back of my hand
I hate the ocean it's my biggest fear
all right we're going shark diving today
we're gonna go out about six miles
offshore in the middle the Gulf Stream
we're gonna throw you guys in water with
some big sharks these are all like
friendly cool sharks right no these are
the bigger more aggressive top three
premiere sharks cruise in the world and
they have to tell people very rarely but
yes it's happened before you're going
out to witness one of the greatest
predators on earth right you're gonna
see them in their environment yeah like
if I were a cartoon character that way
he'll wave so how this dive is gonna
work I'm gonna take a crate full of
tunas I'm gonna put it down about 20
feet
all the Sharks gonna come up and just
circle that crate ready so you guys
ready to jump in the water with 20 bull
sharks right now yeah I'm in that cage
man yeah I'm super chill yeah it's a
perfectly good shark cage but I don't
think we should use it today have you
ever had groups hold hands the entire
time never happened before okay well we
might do that three two one
how's he doing
got a shark shark in the water shark in
the water
listen up really simple alright you got
a lot of sharks here now easiest thing
in the world is to exactly what I said
have one person right in here holding on
to the rope with you down the sharks
swim team other person three-two-three
another person single pot no more going
out there
about a hundred sharks started showing
up below us and I'm not exaggerating it
was like a sea of stumps about fifty
feet below us bull sharks are a pack
animal so you're gonna have like 10 20
30 even at one time and then stop making
all those noises sharks make a living on
picking people off certain acting
sketchy there's more in awe and I can't
stop gripping the cage I like I have my
knuckles are white it was real and they
were very up next me head Ned went from
ocean master to ocean disaster net had
the reaction that I thought I was gonna
have I'm really proud of myself I did
the thing that I said I was never going
to do so the Sharks we had today we're
bull sharks definitely one of the most
aggressive sharks in the world a guy
actually did get attacked that same area
about a week ago Zack went from master
ocean hater to ocean master baiter
think about it it's not a situation
where shark goes out of its way to see
someone and attacks them it's a
situation where the person actually does
something that provokes that attack you
got to come out and see him for what
they really are we were all good
everybody took care of us we knew what
to do we didn't panic nobody died Blake
Lively
it's simple I gotta do is be calm
it felt way too close to death
I need a yeah okay it's okay I was there
with you a lot I know he was struggling